vous avez quatre heures vous vous
souvenez quand nous étions au lycée
juste avant l'épreuve de philosophie du
baccalauréat
et si dans la vie de tous les jours
c'était quatre secondes que nous avions
mais quatre secondes pour quoi faire
9 juillet 2006 finale de la coupe du
monde de football à berlin opposant la
france à l'italie
l'icône du football français zinedine
zidane assène un violent coup de tête au
torse de l'italien materazzi 28 avril
boban djokovic marque un panier
larbitre l'annulent immédiatement
considérant qu'il y à faute offensive
c'est la cinquième faute du joueur il
doit donc sortir du terrain en réaction
à une décision qu'ils estiment injuste
dans une situation cruciale d'un match à
enjeu le joueur perd ses moyens et
adresse encore une fois un coup de tête
au montant du panier c'est pas si drôle
en fait parce que malgré le rembourrage
de ce dernier il sans dommage la moelle
épinière et devient incapable de marcher
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
d'actifs comment expliquer qu'ils aient
pu l'un et l'autre réalisé un acte aux
conséquences si dramatiques
quels sont les points communs entre ces
deux situations
le coup de tête bien sûr le sport de
haut niveau également
mais à mes yeux le sport de haut niveau
n'est qu'un prétexte à exacerber les
émotions parce que la médiatisation
l'économie et l'engagement du corps ils
sont amplifiées au final les
comportements ils sont décuplées
nous sommes tous des pièces à deux faces
chacun de nous a en soi un côté lumineux
et un côté sombre un côté bienveillant
inoffensif d'une part et un côté
critiqué hyper agressif d'autre part et
j'ai pu expérimenter que c'est bien
souvent contre soi même que ce dernier
côté s'exprime
chacun de nous est susceptible à un
moment donné de se retrouver dans une
situation délicate inconfortable et a
devant lui quatre secondes de
conscientisation avant d'adopter le
comportement qui selon sa nature fera
toute la différence en toute situation
nous effectuons une analyse inconsciente
basé sur une construction mentale donc
artificiel donc trompeuse
celle ci nous amène à anticiper
visualiser ce qui se joue comme étant un
danger un échec futur ou bien une future
réussite qui ici est parent qui ici a
des enfants levé la main pour voir au
coach et on est en bonne compagnie je
pense que dans cet endroit pacifiée dans
ce moment pacifiée dans cet endroit
absolument magnifique dans lequel on est
nous sommes globalement tous d'accord
pour dire que nous les aimons
du plus profond de notre coeur vous êtes
d'accord avec ça ok et en même temps
est ce que ça ne vous est pas déjà
arrivé d'avoir envie de les voir se
taire de ne plus les voir quelques
instants seulement bien sûr ça vous est
déjà arrivé je vois qu'on vit les mêmes
choses en fait
et pour finir mais cette fois ci je ne
vous demanderai pas de lever la main qui
ici dans la salle a déjà vécu des
violences lorsqu'il était enfant qui ici
a déjà entendu des propos blessants
retenu vécu des situations anxiogènes
qu'il ou elle porte encore avec lui je
m'appelle nicolas raimbeaux je dédie ma
vie à comprendre comment l'humain
fonctionne en contexte de pression c'est
parce que j'ai pu vivre des situations
de cette nature lors de mes premières
années de vie que s'est dessiné en moi
l'incompréhension de ce genre de
phénomène
c'est à ce moment là en fait lorsque
j'étais enfant que le coeur du réacteur
s'est forgé vous savez le réacteur
celui qui nous fait réagir et dans mon
cas j'ai opté je dirais même que je me
suis forgé une habitude de contrôle pour
certainement ne pas exploser connaissant
bien les dégâts que l'explosion peut
provoquer une approche de métaphysique
chinoise à laquelle je m'intéresse ces
temps ci nous permet de comparer ce que
nous montrons en surface avec ce qui se
cache au plus profond d'entre nous il se
trouve que je suis calme et posée en
surface mais qu'un véritable dragon
sommeil au plus profond de moi que se
cache-t-il eaux plus profondes entre
vous lorsque vous êtes en situation de
pression en situation de tension
que peut-on trouver au plus profond de
l'iceberg qui ne puisse se révéler alors
qu'on ne s'y attendait pas
j'ai continué à vivre ces expériences
lorsque j'étais enfant lorsque j'étais
adolescent car c'est véritablement dans
ces années de vie que des processus
d'exclusion appartenance éminemment
puissants se construisent en termes de
construction de l'identité individuelle
au sein des groupes d'appartenance
pour le dire simplement les groupes
d'appartenance dans le foyer familial
dans les équipes sportives dans lesquels
on peut être au collège au lycée pour ma
part basketteurs en herbe
je n'ai jamais été sélectionné parmi les
meilleurs départementaux ou régionaux du
fait de ma petite taille
étonnante vous dire ça ce soir du haut
de mon mètre 98 n'est qu'au lycée que ma
croissance a véritablement explosé
je vous avoue que ça a été très
difficile à vivre et et même une
véritable souffrance et en même temps
j'ai choisi d'utiliser cette énergie
pour en faire un véritable moteur je
vous invite maintenant à réfléchir à
cette situation cette situation vous
avez été sous tension en pression celle
où vous avez été à deux doigts de
déraper réfléchissez-y un petit peu
avez vous pu remarquer à quel point tout
se passe très vite
avez vous remarqué à quel point tout
peut basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre
tout réside dans le couplage de nos
pensées et de nos émotions
tout se joue en 4 secondes
une première lors de laquelle vous
percevez la situation une seconde lors
de laquelle les motions s'offre à vous
une troisième où la pensée s'installe et
une 4e où vous décidez ces quatre
secondes
c'est ce moment invisible le temps d'une
respiration consciente
alors c
pas celle de stéphane tour au mon ami le
vice champion du monde d'apnée que vous
voyez à l'écran ça serait un petit peu
long pour le coup c'est quatre secondes
constitue ce moment invisible éminemment
puissant qui fait le lien entre l'esprit
et le corps la pensée et l'acte
mais que se passe-t-il dans ces quatre
secondes et si nous pouvions saisir cet
instant préliminaire et si nous pouvions
arrêté temps comment pour en tant qu est
ce là du point de vue du fonctionnement
du cerveau
les neurosciences nous indique que le
circuit neurologiques de la colère
existe bel et bien
ça se joue en fait au niveau de
l'amygdale à l'origine qui crée
l'émotion au sein du cerveau en réaction
aux situations qu'on estime frustrante
ils s'enchaînent une réaction en chaîne
pour le coup qui transitent par les
neurones et qui va vers l'hypothalamus
l'hypothalamus nous sert à activer les
manifestations physiologiques qui sont
associés l'augmentation dû rythme
cardiaque la dilatation des pupilles par
exemple l'information peut aussi une
alternative être traité par le néocortex
le néocortex seiler liés à la pensée
consciente
en faisant cela on appelle ça la voie
lente
c'est une façon de calmer les motions
avant d'engager le comportement
d'agression imaginez vous êtes au
téléphone dans une conversation
essentiels qui requièrent toute votre
attention sur un sujet éminemment
fondamentale et là votre fille votre
fils ou un enfant se plante devant vous
vous pose cinq fois de suite la même
question ne comprenant pas que vous lui
répondez pas voulait déjà vécu ça moi
oui mais que se passe-t-il en nous dans
cet instant quelles sont les options qui
s'offrent à nous la première contenir
l'émotion
certes
la réaction est [ __ ] mais le système
nerveux sympathique continue à
s'emballer avec un effet cocotte-minute
absolument délétères pour la santé
au passage c'est une dérive typique du
développement personnel dans laquelle
j'ai failli tomber j'ai failli ni et mes
émotions en pensant que le zen c'était
ne pas ressentir d'émotion c'était
porter un masque c'était se contenir
c'était ne pas exploser
certainement de peur de l'explosion
justement
l'information peut aussi être donc
traitées par ce néo cortex tu ça permet
de calmer les l'émotion on peut utiliser
le principe de la ré évaluation
cognitive qui consiste à revenir à la
réalité de sorte que la colère
paraissent moins spontané - nécessaire -
indispensable
moi quand je sens que ça commence à être
compliquée pour moi si je me trouve par
exemple dans une situation face à
quelqu'un dont je considère le
comportement comme étant énervant france
ça peut être sur la route ça vous est
déjà arrivé ce genre de choses ce que
j'essaye de faire dans ces moments là
c'est de m'appliquer ces deux techniques
c'est déjà me dire d'emblée que le
comportement ne définit pas la personne
dans cette société où on a vraiment
l'habitude de mettre des étiquettes sur
le front des gens le comportement de
départ ne définit pas la personne
et puis en complément de sa j'essaye
autant que je peux en tout cas de me
dire que derrière tout comportement il y
a toujours une intention positive je
sais ça peut sembler étonnant mais
derrière tout comportement il y a
toujours une intention positive ne
serait ce que pour la personne qu'ils
expriment pour elle même pour se
protéger et puis ce soir je voulais vous
offrir une technique que j'utilise quand
je sens que en moi ça monte en mode
cocotte-minute ce que je fais en telle
situation c'est la chose suivante je
ferme les yeux je visualise un endroit
dans lequel j'adore être je me met à
sourire
quitte à le forcer un peu au début quand
c'est pas si évident que ça et puis ce
que je fais c'est que je fais 4
respiration consciente
vous voyez ce que c'est une respiration
consciente
c'est simplement quand on met de la
conscience sur le fait qu'on fait
respirer bref on se dit qu'on pense
qu'on est en train de restaurer ce qu'on
ne fait jamais d'ailleurs au passage
alors que la médecine chinoise nous dit
que si on en faisait 300 par jour
on serait toujours mais alors toujours
en bonne santé et ce qui est absolument
magnifique c'est que ces techniques là
en fait elles sont toutes au sens utile
lorsqu'on est dans des situations qu'on
peut concevoir comme étant hyper
favorisantes qui ici s'est déjà trouvé
dans cette situation où personne pas
loin là qui vous impressionne un peu
dont vous êtes secrètement ou alors
peut-être secrètement amoureux vous êtes
à quelques mètres d'y aller que se
passe-t-il dans ces quatre secondes où
vous vous dites ok je vais y aller mais
en même temps vous écoutez votre ego
vous projeter vers une future déconvenue
il y associe tout de suite une émotion
de peur et là vous rentrez les épaules
avez-vous fait demi tour et puis vous
pas ou bien vous vous dites mais c'est
une opportunité absolument incroyable en
fait pour une fois c'est peut-être la
seule fois de ma vie que je pouvoir
rencontrer cette personne je prends une
bonne inspiration
j'engage lepage avance et j'y vais que
se passe-t-il dans ces quatre secondes à
ce sujet ma coach pour ce talk m'avait
invité à faire un exercice
il s'agissait de franchir le cap de
l'audace en me mettant en situation
d'aller dans la rue à bord d une
inconnue que je trouvais jolie est
justement le but du jeu était de lui
dire que je la trouvais jolie l'audace
c'est ce petit supplément d'âme qui
guide le pr l'audace c'est faire sauter
le corset et faire sauter le masque
alors que l'ambition c'est l'élaboration
du scénario stratégique laquelle
n'inclut pas nécessairement la mise en
mouvement
la mise en action dans cette situation
l'idée en fait c'est de minimiser
l'impact de l'adrénaline cette hormone
qui est l'hormone du stress et de
mobiliser al'inverse la dopamine votre
allié qui associe plaisir et actions bon
comme c'est comme très important de
toujours être honnête je vous avais que
l'exercice je ne l'ait pas fait en fait
mais il n'est pas trop tard je croyais
qu'il me reste quelques secondes encore
pour faire cela
mademoiselle vous êtes magnifique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au final vous aurez toujours quatre
secondes devant vous il n'y aura certes
pas de professeur pour vous indiquer le
temps restant avant l'a rendu des copies
ou vous donner la conduite à tenir c'est
vous qui êtes maître de ce temps je
considère je sais que ça n'est pas
facile j'en ai conscience
moi ce que je m'efforce de faire c'est
autant que je le peux et je ne suis pas
parfait mais autant que je le peux de
mettre fi de mettre à profit ces quatre
secondes
justement pour aborder le meilleur
comportement celui qui sera le plus
vertueux pour moi d'abord et par
répercussion dans les changes avec
l'autre si l'on ne peut pas voir son
reflet dans l'eau qui bout on ne peut
pas avoir de clarté lorsqu'on est triste
en colère est dépité ces quatre secondes
sont là pour ça pour vous aider à mettre
de la conscience sur ce qui se joue de
sorte d'en dégager de la clarté et au
final d'aborder le bon comportement
maintenant qu'allez vous faire
vous savez ce qu'il y à faire dans ces
quatre secondes et ce qui est absolument
magnifique ce que vous pouvez aussi
déconstruire ces quatre secondes
comment allez-vous utiliser cela je
crois bien que c'est à vous je vous
invite à fermer les yeux et je vous
invite visualiser cette dernière
situation
celle où vous avez franchi cette ligne
rouge
cette où vous êtes emporté 7 vous êtes
sortis de vous peut-être était-ce avec
votre conjoint peut être avec vos
enfants vos parents peut être était ce
travail c'est bon vous l'avez illuminé
l'image agrandie c'est l'image mettez
votre attention sur les sons sur les
bruits comment étiez vous habiller
qu'elle était l'espace dans lequel vous
étiez
aviez-vous chaud aviez-vous froid que
vous disiez vous qu'est ce qui vous
touche et ce soir je vous invite à
revivre cette situation
rien que pour vous et d'en changer
l'issue mais à une condition c'est que
vous n'allez avoir que quatre secondes
pour le faire
qu'allez vous faire 4 3 2 1
c'est à vous
merci
[Applaudissements]